young adults on social media are
increasingly becoming the targets of
hackers and federal data now saying that
cryptocurrency scams have really just
skyrocketed but the 80s now i-teams
vanessa murphy shares some steps to
protect yourself
[Music]
24 year old mary peplin says she thought
she was messaging a friend from high
school on instagram she shared her phone
number and clicked on a link but she
says it turned out to be a scam started
getting messages and phone calls from
friends and family asking me hey mary
are you on your instagram right now
asking me for money i think i had a
panic attack i was mortified i
was crying i was upset i did not know
what to do cryptocurrency scams have
skyrocketed during the pandemic the
federal trade commission estimates since
october of 2020 people ages 20 to 49
were five times more likely to lose
money in these online investment scams
you want to trust your gut if you have a
bad feeling about someone you're talking
to on the internet you want to listen to
those instincts consumer reports
technology writer thomas jermaine says
other steps you can take include not
responding if it's someone you don't
know check before you click on a link
and limit venmo or cash app payments to
friends only peplin called her
experience traumatizing i was being
treated differently by my peers because
they thought you know i'm either a
scammer or i was dumb enough to get
hacked she wants instagram to do more to
protect users like her instagram
provided a statement that reads in part
we have sophisticated measures in place
to stop bad actors in their tracks
before they gain access to accounts as
well as measures to help people recover
their accounts the statement went on to
say we know we can do more here and
we're working hard in both these areas
to stop bad actors before they cause
harm vanessa murphy live local now